i started boxing kickboxing you know i
i was street fighting you know went from
gang
banging to mafioso to wannabe you know
like tony montana all that stuff so you
have to be ready all the time
that's what it is there's like temporary
joys temporary entertainment
that's what i went through and most of
you brothers also can relate you go
through that it's a fading enjoyment
it's like being at the amusement park
and you're waiting in line for 30
minutes an hour sometimes
and then you get off the the ride is the
ride is literally like 45 seconds
somewhere even 30 seconds it's over but
that's the thing
that you have we have to understand
people forget this life will be like
that
you look back like i was looking back
i'm getting old there gray hair is
kicking in
and you're just like where did my life
go the party's over the lights come on
it's finished and that's how life is
going to be
it's going to be over it's done right so
that's what this d in islam it prepares
us for what's coming forever forever
ever
yes forever because everything here is
in the past tense been there
done that how was that oh it was this it
was that it's finished
it's done and that's how our life will
be it'll be finished and then what do we
prepare for the next life that's coming
islam gives us the tools gives us
everything to go through the challenges
life's not perfect we're all going
through struggles but it gives us the
tools
with all these self-help books and
everybody's writing you know
all of these is very popular nowadays
the best self development book
is the quran the sunnah we have it it's
[Music]
[Music]
there
[Music]
it's not up to you to give her your
attention all the time because if you do
then you're you're missing the point
you're not putting allah first
right so if you're not putting on if
you're not putting her first and you're
putting on love first
she's going to be trying to get your
attention all the time with her trying
to get you attention all the time
she's going to be testing she's going to
be doing all these things
and if you fall into her frame
unless you finished bro wallahi you
finished
welcome back to the three muslims
podcast with this podcast in the dunya
and today we have another very special
guest brother eddie from the dean show
saddam alaikum
in the peace mercy and blessings of god
almighty allah be upon all of you
i mean and you and all the viewers at
home insha'allah
bismillah so subhanallah eddie you know
very recognizable face masha allah
in the darwin community um you know host
the dean shalom
may allah reward you for all your work
um subhanallah well i'm curious about
is you know your upbringing and your
journey to islam and your journey on
starting the dean show and how that has
affected you
and those around you the audience and so
on and so forth
really proud of you brothers you guys
doing some wonderful work
accepted from us so uh
yeah alhamdulillah back in 2006
i was planning to go to hajj and
from there it was a lot of intricate
details and i was already passionate
about
about sharing the message about islam
purpose of life
talking to people about this because for
someone who's kind of
been through all the the things of the
dunya
as we call it the days of ignorance and
then you just uh
you know you get excited to share the
truth and you want people to experience
that
that also so those are the the early
beginnings
the humble beginnings that's when like
youtube just just started
uh before that it was like allah guided
me like around
early 2000 i had investigated all the
different religions
i wanted to make sure what i was upon
was based on truth and evidence it
wasn't just a feeling you know what i
mean but
it's interesting that i was and the
because we get programmed kind of to
feel like it's something esoteric you
got to just get this like
you know this wuha feeling and whatnot
and and
i kind of went through that and i would
like be i remember watching late night
tony robbins i'm looking
at that avenue and then i'm like putting
candles and putting some like uh
mystical music and whatnot and i'm just
waiting for some kind of like holy ghost
spirit to come into me and
and have my epiphany my moment and and
that wasn't happening because you
you connected to a feeling i feel good
something that's going to come over you
and then i'm going to people like who
just got the biggest beard and i'm
saying you know can you teach me
something
but alhamdulillah this deen is based on
knowledge and that's the beautiful thing
about islam
when you get grounded it's based on
evidence i'm proof
and when i got grounded in the deen i
started to learn it it started to
convince me intellectually
and then i started to grow spiritually
alhamdulillah we're all works in
progress
so we need to get grounded i started to
get ground and then i just started
naturally i wanted to share
and then i started planning to go to
hajj that was 2006
and from there i recorded it i was in
the midst of either opening up i wanted
to do a dawah center i i
my late teacher dr amir ali may allah
grant him jannah he had a dawah center
here in chicago the triple ie
this is where muhammad ali used to come
and get pamphlets from him and get
his uh put his signature on it and give
it out to the people
and then what happened from there was uh
i was like okay let me
let me do something else like make it
more
where maybe like a coffee shop library
i was just thinking i was asking i lost
my daughter to guide me and then
this took off youtube started i started
to uh go and take some classes at the
can the canned tv studio here in chicago
the cable access
and then the media that was a tool that
you can reach
probably the most people and so i went
that route and then alhamdulillah
you know allah is the one that opens
doors and here we are
uh with you guys today
masha allah masha'allah i have a i have
also a
documentary because a lot of people were
asking me because i interviewed
so many different people get their
stories and they were like what about
you how did you come
to islam so kind of for a longer version
there's and i can give you guys little
highlights here and there
there's a documentary called from dunya
to dean so it takes you from the
beginning stages of my life growing up
like most you understand like
you know being someone who grows up in
america
and you just want to just uh fit in you
want to be popular whatever the case
young boys what they're chasing have the
you know showing off the keys to the car
and then you've got the rims and the
speakers in the back i don't know after
how they do it now but that's how it was
back then
and which crew you can be with and then
it went from you know
looking at people like having you know
the pictures of tony montana
and the uh what's that the good fellows
godfather
and mimicking that lifestyle because
we're all in pursuit of like
we we we're creatures of imitation
that's why allah god almighty he sent
the prophets the messengers to be
imitated in the best of examples prophet
muhammad
peace and blessed be upon him so if
we're not imitating the best of people
who are we imitating a lot of times the
youth
like myself i was imitating right the
wrong people
you know some of the worst people
usually and i was trying to emulate them
and this is just common this is what
happened is that's how i was growing up
and i experienced all that and but then
when i experienced the sweetness of iman
because
all that stuff fades right they asked
the billiard there after he accepted
islam why he was crying
he said because if i wanted the french
food i hired a french chef
if i wanted italian food i hired an
italian chef i wanted
whatever i wanted i had but i never
experienced this delight
when he accepted islam see he had all
the things of the dunya
this is a true story and from there when
he accepted the
shahada he accepted he for those
watching who don't know that's their
testimony of faith
bearing witness giving birth to what's
already in your nature that there's
nothing worthy of worship i'm not going
to worship a human being
an angel a saint i'm not going to
worship my desires my ego
nothing in creation is worthy of worship
except the one who created me the one
who made me that just makes sense
the creator of the heavens and the earth
and everything we say allah and muhammad
is the messenger just like jesus moses
abraham they're all messengers they
didn't call people to worship themselves
but to worship the one and only creator
so when he took that shahada he was just
like most people now because
you all those sins that you've done
you're like a newborn baby
and you experience that gift that
present that gift now and he was like
you know just
you know uh so happy and elated
and all that all those things that he
went through in life it just
that's what it is there are temporary
joys temporary entertainment
that's what i went through and most of
you brothers also can relate you go
through that it's a fading enjoyment
it's like being at the amusement park
and you're waiting in line for 30
minutes and hours sometimes
and then you get off the the ride it's
the ride is literally like 45 seconds
some are even 30 seconds it's over but
that's the thing
that you have we have to understand
people forget this life will be like
that
you look back like i was looking back
i'm getting older
gray hairs kicking in and you're just
like where did my life go
the party's over the lights come on it's
finished and that's how life is going to
be
it's going to be over it's done right so
that's what this d in islam it prepares
us for what's coming forever forever
ever
yes forever because everything here is
in the past tense been there
done that how was that oh it was this it
was that it's finished it's done and
that's how our life will be
it'll be finished and then what do we
prepare for the next life that's coming
islam gives us the tools gives us
everything to go through the challenges
life's not perfect we're all going
through struggles but it gives us the
tools
with all these self-help books and
everybody's writing you know
all of these is very popular nowadays
the best self development book
is the quran and the sunnah we have it
it's there
so alhamdulillah now so just trying to
get this out trying to get this message
you know out this message that can help
improve people definitely improve
people's lives the solution to
many of the social ills and just trying
to do our small part you know to make a
difference inshallah
inshallah may allah reward you for uh
the work that you do masha'allah
uh subhanallah so it's basically the
difference between you know short-term
gratification and long-term
gratification and you know what's more
long-term than
eternity in in jannah um or for some
people
in hell allah protect us from that i
mean
subhanallah so how how does one start
from you know with detaching from the
world and and getting closer to allah
i like to say roi what's the return on
our investments and taking
things to the end to the ultimate
extreme if i continue
doing things and i always picture
talking to the people who are kind of
going through and if you do
statistically the numbers
like because sometimes we get so
disattached
like myself and i forget what's going on
i i kind of knew i was more
adept to what was happening because i
was just coming over from that lifestyle
now i just like at my life before i
could not imagine myself
spending time on a farm uh being in the
green
it was just living in a concrete jungle
being in the suburbs or away from the
city was something unimaginable right
because the action was where
in the city that's where it was at now
my life is like it's i i want to be away
from the cities i want to be away from
the concrete jungles i want to be
more in touch with nature you know you
get to know the creator from his
creation
so i guess the first part you know for
many people is to really
weigh things out if what's the return on
my investment if i just keep living this
type of life
you know how is it good for my soul how
is it good for my development where is
it leading me if i continue drinking
alcohol every 10 seconds someone is
dying from alcohol
every 10 seconds if i continue
fornicating if i continue just going
from
you know because ideal allah says in the
quran this is something that
is it's just clear you know what men
desire most
is the desire for women so at that age
most men they get the nice cars they get
the nice material things for what so
they can impress the women
so if i'm just going to be womenizing if
i'm going to just you know be jumping
from one woman to the next if i'm just
going to be
looking to have the material goods
material things like if you look at the
mayweathers if we look at you know the
conor mcgregors
you know some of these people are very
popular you can see you know
the people just uh having the bling
bling having you know
all the material things and that's what
they live for they end up kind of
worshiping
that but i compare it to being on a
plane you just wake up one day and
you're on this plane
and this plane now you're like it's
gonna land soon
and so you have to ask yourself okay
like am i just gonna go ahead and
uh look at the entertainment that they
have on the box there
uh or i'm gonna like just kind of figure
out how did i get here on this plane
and where is it headed it's headed
towards the destination this plane is
gonna land very soon
now equate that to life so many things
distracting us so many things out there
that are just like
you know keeping us away from just
pondering and thinking like what's the
purpose of life
why am i here where i come from where am
i going
so think of these basic questions i tell
people just think about it
think about how my life i'm living it
now am i truly happy is my
am i content you know people end up
jumping off a building these are true
stories
you know they end up losing they got one
billion they lose half of it they got
half
they got 500 million left but they don't
have that contentment they don't have
that peace they have they don't have
that purpose they end up jumping off
bridges committing suicide
so most people are not happy but they're
living for them they're living through
the means so when you ask people like
why am i here
okay to have a family we know these are
means right
half of your half of your dean like is
when you get married so that's a means
you know okay it's to have this job then
you lose the job you have this marriage
you get divorced
okay you make a certain money and then
what you got to have body guards
you got to have bags you have all this
stuff to protect it maybe you lose it
more stress more anxiety that was our
means okay
islam doesn't block you from any of
these things but what's the ultimate
purpose
and goal so i just start to drop these
things and start to really have people
to just to think common sense is really
common sense right
so and and then from there just have
people to kind of get out of there
because the fitra
is there and every the fit there's a
natural disposition to kind of
have awakened this because it's been
covered with layers and layers of layers
so if we can get people to think and to
reflect and then we can go if if someone
opens up and then we can go into many of
these other things
you know uh that are laid out uh in the
dean so that's where i usually start to
have
people to kind of just reflect over the
basics
you know that we're gonna die there's a
purpose you know we need to meet
you know and comparing it to everything
around us has a purpose that bike see
that bike behind you
i like the bike rami the picture of the
bike
if you look at this basic stuff we can
you know look at the spokes on the wheel
the tires
if you ask somebody find me one thing on
that bike
behind our brother rami that doesn't
have a purpose even from the nuts and
bolts
you cannot find that but what about the
person riding the bike
doesn't make any sense that he she don't
have a purpose how about that punching
bag behind my brother
you hitting that a lot brother
the bag see the bag look at that bag it
has a purpose it's to be punched but it
has a purpose
right so that's nice you guys are doing
riding bikes
all sorts i got my brother with the
stick over there
yeah it's out the frame right now but
it's yeah
it's there alhamdulillah
we had a guest on here a while back uh
correct me if i'm saying his name wrong
sheikh fahad yeah
man he said the same thing he said that
like it's basically like you're on a
plane
and you don't know where this plane is
going but it's like
well do you ask like do you try to
figure it out or do you just kind of sit
there
and just wait until it arrives
with like no you know no want to eat or
desire to actually figure it out
and i think that's what most people are
doing nowadays is they don't want to
figure it out they're trying to uh
uh distract themselves like you said
with entertainment that's provided
yeah that's i'm so happy when you see
brothers you have to make this is
because it it has this uh stigma
sometimes attached to it
you know talking about these things but
when you see cool brothers such as
yourself this is something cool to talk
about it's something that
should be talked about so when we see
young brothers like yourselves
talking about these important topics
talking about purpose this will
gravitate towards others
because now people are making other
topics cool which are not so cool in the
dean right
useless you know just wasted time a lot
of things are just about haram things
you know that's just you know helps a
person to acquire std a spiritually
transmitted disease
but this is something that just awakens
the hearts to minds the soul and this is
what gives it life you know
truly in the remembrance of allah of god
almighty do the hearts find rest and i
remember
when i it's a it was a really simple
book i was reading a brief illustrator
guide to understanding islam and it had
this eye in there
and when i read this ayah i started to
just like [ __ ] a tear start coming to my
eye because i felt like that i was
feeling that like
that that contentment that peace you
know that allah is saying in the quran
truly in the remembrance of allah do
hearts find the rest and my heart was
restless
restless and i remember it's comparing
it to like a child
who just keeps crying and crying and
crying and everyone's trying to you
bring the child
and the uncle sees it the ant and it's
just like crying why is he crying cannot
stop crying but then it goes back to its
mother
ah it's that peace that's the soul when
you bring that soul back to its creator
it's at peace mashallah
i have a question it's a side question
but i have a question on the list
when you were going on about this you
said that you started off in the city
and that you wanted to be there because
that's where the action was at you said
now that you're in
in nature and all that stuff uh what are
you what are you doing now do you
you do farming and all that right now i
have some chickens
i have uh some sheep so you know
i'm really into i'm trying to be into
i went through another journey in life
where for a lot of for a long time i was
working that's been a part of my life i
started boxing kickboxing
you know i i was street fighting you
know went from
gang banging to mafioso to wannabe
you know like tony montana all that
stuff so you had to be ready
all the time right you had to be you
know so boxing was my thing and then
and but working out but i was eating
whatever i wanted to eat
right i really wasn't too i it was like
okay you you work out you can just
eat whatever you want it wasn't it
wasn't uh
that bad but i was still eating a lot of
fake processed foods
but then i got to a point in my life
where i started get sick it starts to
catch up with you
so i started to get sick i had some
bronchitis like coughing a lot what not
and then i was also like most of us you
get programmed there's a pill for every
ill
you watch the because the united states
and i think new zealand are the only two
countries that now they have
direct advertisement to the public
through the pharmaceutical company other
countries
don't so now you watch this and you go
to the doctor and you're just like hey
give me this pill this magical pill and
i was like you know programmed like this
so i'd want an antibiotic for everything
just enter and you and it work in the
beginning you start to feel a little
better
but suddenly that stuff starts creating
more problems in the gut and
in other places and it starts losing its
effect
and we live in a society now where also
doctors you know have some great doctors
out there but
they're pressured also and you come in
and you
you want something right a quick fix and
a lot of them also they get see so many
patients
five minutes ten minutes and they just
start passing out the drugs you know
they become drug pushers for the
pharmaceutical companies a shame
not all doctors but many have fallen
into that trap those who don't have that
integrity
you know who who um are are not
in that profession who also you know
this is a big thing they
they have money on their mind and ego
and they just about you know
uh reputation i'm a doctor this that and
the other and many have gone away from
really what a doctor's about
really really trying to really heal
people so they give other doctors a bad
name so anyways that's another story but
so then i ended up getting turned out to
uh
one of the uh nutritionists that
was well known here um in chicago he's
an
older gentleman he was a chief
nutritionist for dr mercola
uh here at the optimist wellness center
and i was getting into this raw milk
well this is this is interesting because
many people when you say raw milk that
right away they're programmed because of
the dairy industry
is this going to make you sick right
even though at one point
when they were processing the raw milk
it was
in a dirty environment it was next to
many alcohol distillery
tills but then when i did my research i
started to really investigate you know
looking into this raw milk
i saw man this is so many health
benefits you know when you homogenize
you pasteurize it
you end up killing killing the enzymes
that help with digestion that's why the
fda has milked
as the top one of the top food allergies
people have is milk but why because it's
gone through the human process
right and i and i often compare it you
know when the prophet saw someone he
went on israel
right no no when he was offered i'm
sorry there's another story with hijab
but
he was offered wine or milk what did he
choose
he chose what milk right so we often
hear this study the milk does a body
good anyway so
i really got into i was i was into like
the raw goat
milk raw milk and then i met this
nutritionist
and uh and then from there he just
turned me out to really eating real food
avoiding fake food
and good things started to happen this
body has an innate
system inside it's always going towards
healing it's always going towards
healing
but now we put things in its way that
hinder this healing
and that's what i was doing by putting
this garbage you know allah didn't make
this body as a garbage can and we put
garbage in it
so i was putting garbage in the body and
then what was happening i was making it
sick
but then alhamdulillah i ended up
putting the good nutrition in the body
sort of educated myself started to talk
to holistic doctors you know
this nutritionist it's a whole different
science i learned that doctors do not
study
do not learn about nutrition in medical
school that opened my eyes i said
how did they not learn nutrition in
medical school and now
they're going to end up teaching you
when you go to the doctor you take your
kid
to the doctor and they got a vending
machine with cookies
with snicker bars you know that's
actually doing the opposite
so that's that's what happened so uh now
back to your question original question
is grass-fed grass-fed meat right
this is this is true taibat as allah
says in the quran chapter 2
i think 171. um
oh you who believe eat of the good food
this is in in the quran why this is the
truth so
so i like to to get um to be in that
environment see the animals and then if
i slaughter
you know um go ahead and have that gr
that grass fed
right with all the without all the
antibiotics and all the other junk that
they feed the animals and then you're
eating this and then
that's why people end up getting sick so
that environment you know is just very
peaceful and
that's what i like to be when i'm when
i'm able to get away from the city
i would love to drink raw milk but i've
been lactose intolerant for like
geez i can't even remember how long now
okay oh that's
that's the number one issue if you try
raw milk try it
most people become lactose intolerant
because they're drinking pasteurized
homogenized milk i was also the same
thing
same thing so i was drinking homogenized
pastry
pasteurized milk i couldn't drink it
because of this
but then the people who started to
switch over
this was gone now right so
they have a i think it's a raw uh raw
milk.com there's a big movement now
you know you get on a co-op you get
anyone who's tried it
it's like a meal in itself you know what
i mean it's just you have to go
and it's interesting that coca-cola
pepsi all this stuff is legal but
raw milk in some places it's been
illegal it's crazy
but now there's a movement to change
this all right so i've got some
i've got some videos and i've
interviewed some farmers how they give
them a hard time and
how they're fighting against this and
i've interviewed uh
some nutritionist talking about the
benefits of raw milk so i would just
encourage just
to try it you know what i mean to try
and see how your body adapts
see how how it is you know what is it
what does it taste like
it tastes sweet uh and the enzymes i
used to when i drank the other milk
you get really bloated but when you
pasteurize it those enzymes they're not
there anymore
but the raw milk they're there so they
help in the digestive system
and all the other the proteins the
minerals that it has great nutritional
value
i i used to that with some raw uh honey
unheated raw honey it's like a meal in
itself
yeah it's been a while now it's been a
while last time i
drank raw was in bosnia some raw
uh you can watch this video i did with a
farmer and we got some raw
goat's milk and he was talking about the
fastest man i forgot who what his name
was
that this is he drank this is all he was
drinking was this type of milk
in the interview he talked about it yeah
great benefit did this just think that
look it's like uh
these these things that sometimes
thinking outside the box
because there's a lot of social pressure
social conditioning way that people
think
but now you kind of like you go outside
the box
and you investigate you think obviously
you'll jump in blindly do your research
and then from there you praise the
harder and you
go for the goal all right so another
question to follow up with that
now that you're doing this type of
lifestyle are you eating bread
uh bread no i'm not eating bread i don't
i don't need it
i don't need uh now listen i would eat
if the bread
depending on what kind of ingredients
were in the bread like how they used to
make bread but the bread today there's
no nutritional value what's
whatsoever and i've noticed many people
who have followed
this who have gotten away from these
empty carbs
who have tried been trying to lose
weight as soon as they cut out these few
things like sugar
i'm not talking about the sugar you get
in dates and apples with the fiber that
the system goes down well
i'm just talking about the sugar and the
fake foods the process refined sugars
once you cut and it's in it's in all and
it's in 500 000
of these uh fake food items if you go
down into the supermarkets
you got the middle aisles it's all fake
food
all fake food but then you go to a
little area to decide it says healthy
food
so obviously what's the rest of the food
all right so now in the pastas and the
sauces there's a great documentary i
always recommend people to watch called
fed up
and it just print points and shows how
all of these foods they just been and
then what actually happened you know
with
again going back to the food industry
fat free and there's another uh
documentary called uh sugar i believe it
was and all like the healthy
what they have like these healthy foods
fat free just any other all this stuff
is garbage
man so no i don't eat i don't need bread
it's a lot of empty carbs and and you'll
see
how the weight comes off for people who
are trying to lose weight when you cut
some people think like it's unimaginable
how can you live without bread again i
have nothing it's the ingredients how
the bread is made that's
that's the main thing yeah some things
that i
have found researching uh the bread
that's made nowadays
is actually an incomplete food meaning
that it's never actually fully cooked
so it's it's never the uh what they
i think is some enzymes or bacteria or
there's a fermenting process that has to
occur
for it to fully cook and if you if you
cut into a loaf of bread and you look at
like
the little circles they look like little
circles like
inside of the bread if they're really
tiny circles that means it was never
fully cooked
but if you if you get a loaf of bread
that's like a real loaf of bread like
those circles are huge circles inside of
the bread and that's a fully
fermented and cooked piece of bread and
on on side of that
uh the main protein source from bread
and gluten is actually not digestible
it can't be digested 100 so everyone on
this world
is a gluten intolerant to an extent
and here we are eating something that we
can't fully digest it's not fully cooked
but it's being pushed exactly yeah and i
think there was i was eating this
ezekiel bread that's in the freezer and
a lot of these gluten-free
breads there's some of these i'll eat or
if home cooked with
almond flour or depending again going
back to the ingredients but 100
what you're saying i know what you're
talking about yes and this imagine if
it's not digestible what is doing to
sit in your system right and then we
wonder a lot of times
and that's the key point then when you
go to the doctor who's supposed to be
helping you out
he doesn't connect it so when i went to
a holistic doctor
right away the doctor said cut out cut
out
i think it was cut out the dairy cut out
the gluten
and connected back to nutrition so
that's a holistic approach
right but most doctors you go to and i'm
not trying to bash on doctors
they end up just giving you what uh a
drug you know
okay so with that being said now that
you have
this form now that you've been eating
better uh
has is your diet 100 sustainable from
the farm or do you still get some things
like
from the grocery stores or something
like that i think if we can
one one just make it easy for people
it's really simple
so i give people i passed down what i
learned from from my
nutritionist uh jim marlowe this
very simple easy eat real food avoid
fake food
eat real food that's like white belt
level without making it complicated
real food is fake food is food that
comes with a list of ingredients that
you can't pronounce you need a chemistry
biology degree
okay so that food should be avoided so
if you can start to eat at home that's
another
gain right there you're on top of things
because you know what's going in the
food
so cooking at home having you know
someone who's
there you're cooking your wife's cooking
you know at home i know you when you
even say wife cooking nowadays it's like
what you're talking about cooking
is that but look so if you have your
because you got to be on page
i'm sure all your brothers are married
now people got two three wives
so when you when you have your wives
cooking uh
you guys are also helping out obviously
doing your part you know
so from here you're already ahead of the
game because you're cutting out the msg
they put in the foods you know the
canola oil
all that stuff that just rains havoc on
the body inflammation
there's a great book by madiha dr madiha
had said called
holistic it's called holistic mx really
great book
and she go she's a holistic doctor and
she goes into
how most of these you know the canola
oil and many of these fake processed
foods they they cause inflammation in
the body
and that's how you end up getting
chronic diseases so
what's going back to your question yeah
so with the meats and that if i if i
it's hard to be hundred percent because
we live in a society it's
it's it's fake food all around us it's
about convenience
you know a lot of times uh you don't
have
you're sometimes a person lazy to cook
for themselves so you go out
so i can understand that uh but if we
can get to about 80 percent
right we can get 85 percent man that's
not bad it's really good if we can work
up
right start cutting out certain things
usually i say sugar
get away go to war and sugar go to war
on sugar look at it if you
if you look at it willpower will only go
so far but if you look at it as your
enemy if you look at it like this does
my body no good
i'm actually every time i put it in
there it's seven times more addictive
than cocaine they've been studies where
the brain lights up
so if i look at this like man this it's
not about those like
you know people often say i look at when
they do this and i
would try to replace this with other
things you take the kid to the school
and they give them lollipops
and they give them this garbage you're
creating sugar addicts
it's like i say why don't you give
someone look if you do if you drink
if you smoke one cigarette it's not a
problem what what's gonna happen that
one cigarette's gonna
turn two to three you're gonna become a
nicotine addict same thing with the
sugar you create sugar addicts so you're
projecting
your sugar cravings on the kids and then
what's going to happen
and then from from their teeth roth
rotting out kids at a young age needing
root canals makes no sense
and then from there obesity 70 percent
of now
americans are over be so overweight kids
are at the first generation of kids not
expected to outlive their parents
it's crazy right cancer great it's all
connected to the food choices 95
of it's connected to the food choices
that we make
so we can start to really go to war on
sugar get out these vegetable oils
canola oil
you know cut out the fake foods eat the
thai bat allah gave us
the good foods look at the for if you
want something sweet you got dates
bananas apples you got vegetables you
got okay grass-fed
beef you got uh chicken you got so many
good foods out there
just avoid the fake ones and we'll be on
our way to better health
and better clarity and this will help
with our worship aribada
you follow me yeah it's a holistic
approach
but in regards to what you have right
now your form like
is that no not not a 100 no no no
because it takes a lot lot more
it'll take a lot more work and effort so
no not 100 sustainable no
yeah okay well that makes sense
mashallah the fact that you built that
up already mashallah is amazing
uh now i'm a bit curious about this
because um
one a hundred percent we we should
encourage people to start somewhere
so i think that's a an amazing place to
start cutting out sugars and all that
masala because that is
is like you said it's one of the most
addictive uh
drugs or substances uh in the world and
the reason i say drugs because it
becomes something
of the sort in the sense that it could
be just as addictive or even more
like you said it's more addictive than
cocaine that's crazy but um
i have two questions one if you're
cooking in your kitchen
isn't like for example the meat that
you're you're cooking
already coming from animals that were
fed a bunch of things to make the
the muscles a little more inflamed and
make them
um they're not antibiotics
part of me you talking about steroids
and antibiotics yes
thank you yes so isn't the meat that
you're already cooking in your kitchen
already you know uh coming from animals
that were fed
these things yeah yeah that's a good
point that's remember
what i mentioned earlier yeah trying to
avoid that by having
now the the animals who are humanely
raised
who are eating what they're designed to
eat so they're grass-fed that's the term
grass-fed
so now if they're grass-fed they're
eating what they're supposed to eat
now what happens with these other
animals in in the
in the dairy farm in the in the farming
industry what they do is
now they end up feeding them corn
they're feeding them grains they're
feeding them things that they're not
designed to eat they get sick
and then they're pumping them on
antibiotics with drugs
and that's the meat that i should be
avoided and that's the meat that
now they've done studies that can
actually make you sick so this is
exactly what you're talking about yeah
but now when you say grass-fed you know
hopefully organic grass-fed this is
something that
was at one time it was just the way it
was the normal way yeah and now because
of production because of money
profits bottom line people start end up
doing unethical things and cutting
corners and that's why we have so many
sick people
being so is how how easy or difficult is
it to get your
your hands on grass-fed meat
depend i guess where where do you guys
uh where do you live
we're near toronto yeah toronto i live
in
florida you're in florida yeah so
usually if you can if you can hook um
hook up with uh like in different places
i guess where where you're at you have
if you want to depending on how far you
want to go
uh sometimes this is already packaged
and done for you grass fed
um it's more expensive if you hook up
you go to like a
amish farm or if you're able to um
go ahead and have a co-op with
with um a group of people and buy
let's say some meat um
what i like to do is have
let's say you go ahead and you have your
animal
and then you prepare this and you let's
say you go to the farm
you can arrange this and if you have a
good freezer
you can go ahead and your house do this
maybe
uh every three four months you go
slaughter get your own meat it takes
it's work you know what i mean it takes
some effort some work
uh how far you want to go yeah and then
you go ahead and get this all prepared
and you have it safe for you and you
just cook this up you know
um and when you're done you go to and
again and do it again
or you can go um and find at some of
these uh
places where they sell grass-fed beef
it's there it's out there yeah
okay you know it's crazy
is that a lot of people know this a lot
of people know
that um eating whole foods is best and
um eating
grass-fed meat is best but they
keep getting swayed by these uh these
infomercials like oh no meat is bad
meat is bad for you and then next thing
you know all saturated fat is bad for
you next thing you know
dates are bad for you next thing you
know it everything is bad for you
and it's like you live in this time
where it's like people
have access to it they have access to
the knowledge but they're not doing
anything with it and
if you look into this yourself anyone
watching right now like
there's one thing that you'll find is
that a lot of these people who are onto
the whole foods approach the holistic
approach
they all say the same thing let food be
thy medicine
yes and it's like you can literally like
with the grace of allah you can heal
your body
with the good food what did you say was
the word for it
yes yes
that's uh if you guys i'll give you uh a
little recipe
after after um brother uh fajit and um
brother rami like could you i see the
bag and then uh
the bike you guys finished working out
the brad's finished you probably maybe
already uh
maybe know about this the uh again you
say this
and the people right away you have to
look here's what i say you have to
before if you tell i'm i'm at the point
where you if you share something with me
it's not that i'm going to take
everything right i'm going to just
blindly
but my mind is open and i also compare
this with people of the sunnah people of
the way
our minds are open if if an eye if if
someone brings me something if i'm doing
something
one way and now you bring me a hadith
you bring me ayah from quran
i have to be ready to adjust my way of
life that's what people of the sunnah
now same thing with life if you bring me
a life hack as they call it
you bring me something that there's some
benefit it might make me
feel uncomfortable for a little bit it
might taste not so good
but that's the problem we got to
re-educate our taste buds
right re-educate our minds so now you
bring me something
and you're just oh no but hold on man
just
read into it look into it study what i'm
saying and then from there
you start to see wow yeah i wasn't so
close-minded
so now if i talk to you about uh raw
eggs for instance
right see
so now you remember that rocky film when
uh
rocky was at one or two and then he was
preparing he had the raw eggs in there
now when you finish uh working out
riding the bike
you take again from healthy chickens
you know um without the antibiotics
humanely raised chickens
you take some raw eggs you put some
maybe some raw milk or some
some almond milk and you put maybe a
banana to sweeten it if you want some
honey
you mix it up you got a protein shake
right there
delicious you follow me but
uh most people are gonna be like but the
people who have have
have tried it it's like wow it tastes
great
or you can just do it the warrior way i
got a video out there with my
nutritional stage he's actually breaking
it on his
how they used to do it on the sharp uh
cane tooth
and then sucking it in so what would you
what would you say to people that are
like what about salmonella poisoning
uh see again from uh very rare
um also again humanely raised chickens
uh my nutritionist who is recommending
the raw milk who's
the raw foods look i i cook foods
uh but he was saying that he didn't have
in his i don't know how many years see
what happens is
in many cases people they capitalize off
one
instant and they magnify that and they
sphere
they put the fear into you for for that
so statistically something that's so
small
right but has so many great advantages
here now
what happens is because this is
something that
now people develop this fear of
something
that is very you know again you do your
research i'm not
trying to uh persuade you to to do it
but just
it's something that you guys just being
open-minded you know some out there
you can try and add it and see how you
like it but do your research first look
into it
you know see see what you come up with
and
see what since we're talking about this
topic yeah i got i got a question for
you but i'm going to ask you off the air
so
i'm going to wait for them all right so
i was going this is just one more thing
before i
so this is a it's just a way of life
it's a way you're looking for ways
different hacks again one man's food not
a man's poison
some people now uh have to give up
certain foods
because they have an allergic reaction
you follow me some foods people end up
doing better with
right you do a food allergy test and
maybe now you have to give up mushrooms
you have to give up eggs you have to
stay away from it
and a lot of these things they say
connected because some of the shots that
people took in
earlier years now they've developed some
food allergies
and now they have to give up certain
foods because of some
something they put in their body before
that's a whole different topic for
discussion yeah
bro that's honestly what i was going to
ask you off the air but i don't know if
uh
yeah we could talk about that if you
want later whatever i know yes so
uh with regards to what you said if you
mix it with honey
uh in theory all right don't quote me on
this don't go out there and like try
this and then get sick and then be like
yo it's your fault
but um in theory and honey is a natural
antibiotic
so if you're mixing that with the raw
chicken if there is salmonella then it
would
uh pretty much negate the salmonella
they would
destroy the salmonella but that's in
theory guys i mean don't quote me on
that i'm not
i'm not some guru when it comes to these
things
much we're going to have to uh
do some research on that or test it
ourselves
come out with the case study but um
subhanallah i i'm curious about if you
have any any sources because you said
you know dear racist yourself is there
anything you
recommend or anything specifically it's
here towards the sudden we know you know
like black seeds and honey yes
so yeah i got a video out there it's
called
uh it's on hijab forgotten sunnah
the prophet saw said you know the
benefits of reviving a sunnah
right so much reward so i really
recommend people
you know to look into and that goes back
to remember when islam is
the ascension and then when he went to
the certain stations
why would i ask people why would one of
the angels
the angels say um have your people do
hijab authentic hadith
why think about that so this is
something that now even these
celebrities they take the rock had a
picture
he's doing the cupping you know i i
don't know if it's dry or wet cupping
so this is something from the sunnah
right that we see
that now has tremendous uh uh
potentially have
can have tremendous uh health benefits
hijama
but again it's something that you've
people are
again programmed back to the pills
and then you take this pill and a true
story i had my just my father had a
stroke
and then tried to get him into the to
rehab but then had to get his blood
pressure down
and they you know medications have their
place
so he was on this medication that one
and then it's causing this pain
and then in the hospital they got all
this
garbage food that's making the the
the uh blood levels go the sugar levels
go up and then they gotta pump him with
this drug
and then he's got a cramp in this lake
from the insulin then you gotta give him
a painkiller he's on 13 different
medications and no
nobody's talking about food nobody's
talking about nutrition that's like
nothing they don't study
so um this is so extreme extremely
extremely important you know so back to
this thing is
the hijab is one is one of those things
you know uh
the the uh the one third one third one
third you know
uh because the root of disease look is
usually from the stomach
but then even before this hadith before
we get to the center of the hadith
in the beginning is enough for the son
of adam is a few more souls right
to keep his back upright to keep him
going a lot of times people jump into
the one third one third right
and i was amazed when i started eating i
just started losing a lot of weight
i started to eat the real food you know
it has
so much uh nutritional
value in there that it gives you what
you need so you're not always craving so
i was eating much less i was like how
can you do that
i was like i i didn't i i
i obviously you believe it but jin
you're just like in practice
how can you just take a few morsels and
just keep you going but i was at one
point i was drinking the milk some honey
i was good i was you know some dates or
some you know
and but i was losing i was losing a lot
of weight but i was feeling my energy
was better
and uh because those [ __ ] all that sugar
cravings from the fake foods it wasn't
it wasn't there
and my body i was given it wouldn't need
it there's a whole
whole thing in the fitness industry how
uh you need like one gram of protein per
pound of body weight
so if you're going out of your weight so
let's say 180 200 grams of protein in
the day
then you kind of do have to eat a lot of
food all right so
what would you say to that depending
that if you're like
depending what you're involved in if
you're a bodybuilder you're looking to
put on muscle
right but if we're just like if you're a
better one in the desert if you're just
or just like living
you know simple life you don't need you
don't need much to survive you don't
need much
much food you know you know there was a
90 there was a good documentary
it's uh it was a scientist i'm sorry
it was it's out there i forgot the name
of it you can find it uh
he was out there trying to see how a
person was uh
living so long he was like over 100
years old he was running a marathon
and one thing in this documentary
pointed out was the
the the intermittent fasting he did
these tests
what we do so that's another thing from
the sunnah fasting
with the intermittent fasting
and then also they asked the man very he
was very thin
lean how he ended up he's running a
maritime marathon he's like over
100 years old and he said what i eat
he said i just eat very small portions i
don't eat much
and that reminded me of this uh hadith
right because like the brother like our
brother was saying this statement like
uh let food be your medicine medicine be
your food there's another statement
that persons should be
living eating to living to eat instead
of eating to live
or vice versa right so we people end up
living just for food that's it just to
eat eat
eat that's it they're just davar all day
you know what i mean
but really in actuality the food is a
source of energy to get us going
just enough so we can go ahead and be
productive with our name we're just not
just living
just to eat that's not the focus of life
it's almost like it's nourishment and
vitality it's not like people are
beautifying and glorifying food
yeah oh yeah for sure for sure sure yeah
if you think about the protein
fired uh in reality if you weren't
working out
just to have like enough protein to
survive like
honestly like 30 grams to 50 degrees is
more than enough
but if you're working out it's actually
like 0.6 to 0.8
and the whole 1 gram per pound of body
weight they just say that because like
most people nowadays they don't measure
their food they don't know exactly how
much they're getting
but um even the 0.6 to uh 0.8 that's
per kilogram not per pound
so there's a lot of not miscommunication
but misinformation when it comes to the
family it's more tied to your lean body
mass too
if you're just 200 pounds you don't even
have muscles then you don't need 200
grams of protein
have you guys any of you tried hijama
never bro i really wanted to try
it i mean i really recommend you guys
and then you could talk about it on your
program
okay so i was wondering how do you how
do you know like who near you is good
you get what i mean like for example
like uh let's say i want to go to a
family doctor
right there's a couple near me but some
are not good yeah
i guess word of mouth or you know
someone recommends someone
it's not really complicated it's very
straightforward it's very it's very
straightforward it's not that
complicated and then they have some
people who completed some courses
so i guess if someone has a good
reputation you know comes as a good
referral
and i'm sure you should be able to find
someone there in canada
yeah yeah yeah there's uh there's a
brother on tick tock
uh fire named slahidin he lives i think
um
he was close to toronto and mississauga
somewhere in between
um i'm forgetting the name but um he
does hijab and the kurokya and and all
this stuff so insha'allah bro we can go
to them together
calm down so it's basically just wet
cupping so they
the the blood is extracted with all the
toxins and
yes it seems very good and it seems like
medically you know it's
it's valid and all that it's obviously
not modern allopathic medicine
right so it's not pushed with big pharma
um
which has a lot of side effects and all
that but i definitely will give it a try
bro
inshallah let me know after
inshallah how was your first experience
with uh with hijab i've been doing it
for such a long time i don't
i i'm trying to remember the first time
i remember there was i had a guest
who left me with a kit um i don't know
if it was uh wassam
wassam sharif he came out one time and
um was it him who did it with me or left
me the kid that was another
from canada i think it was it was a no
was it canada or texas
it was a brother of texas i'm sorry it
was a brother
he's a he's a holistic doctor
and in his practice he has the cupping
and he was educating me on it and
talking about it and um
it was him or samantha wassam sharif who
left me
with the actual kit you know what i mean
so um
uh i've been doing it so and i did a
video you can watch it
where uh you can see it on my channel
where
i take you through the whole process and
then the brother who's doing it
he's really good he breaks down okay
this is step one step two
the benefits of it he calls the the the
hadith
and then at the end i have a medical
doctor medical doctor
who talks about it you know from a
medical perspective who's done some
research
and gives the benefits from that so i
don't remember the first time
uh it's been quite a while and i've been
doing it
and your youtube channel is just the
dean show right same name
tv all right we will put that in the
description
make sure to check it out guys
insha'allah and brother we'll let you
know insha allah
or i can only speak for myself
insha'allah let you know once i do it
um what goes down everything i'll text
you how the
how how it went yo let's get it we'll
get it sometime soon inshaallah
if you guys do want to know more on you
know natural immunity
um antigens uh vaccines and
you know kind of more on it in detail
covert and all that
don't take our advice watch the episode
right before this
the episode right before this it's uh
it's a medical doctor that we got
by the name of dr omar zaid who uh
pretty much just wanted on vaccines if
you guys are interested into that
but yeah without further ado bro let's
uh let's end it off with uh one last
question
actually okay i have one question but i
have to pre-face it with one question i
brought two questions very simple very
simple very simple
uh so you said you had uh lactose
intolerance
before you got into the whole raw milk
and all this other stuff right
yeah i didn't have i did i didn't i
didn't
milk didn't go well done for my body you
know i didn't have i couldn't
drink that regular milk now yeah so were
there other foods as well
that didn't work well with your body um
i found out eggs and actually the milk
okay hold up hold on hold on so eggs you
ate normal eggs like from the soil like
the conventional eggs and what would
happen would you get like bloated
no no uh the i i just did a food
sensitivity
and then i was marked on there oh bro
have you have you ever done one of these
two sentences how does that work
it's they just prick they take some uh
they take some blood
and now you have different um groups you
can do seven
you can do like 70 80 or 100 and then
they tell you okay
it kind of takes the guesswork out of
because there's certain foods you can
eat maybe you get a headache
maybe it makes you tired fatigued right
you don't feel your best
so it kind of takes the guesswork out of
it so you take this test and then you're
like wow i've been eating mushrooms
and here i'm i have a sensitivity to it
maybe i need to cut this out
because that could be affecting me here
another thing is
uh people don't connect the mouth with
the rest of the body so you can have
this a whole different discussion these
uh
you know infected teeth you finally have
an infection in the mouth
then you had these meridian lines these
lines you know the blood
travels and then you got inflammation
here you got joint problems
you have uh you know some other issues
in the body and it's not connected
you're not connecting it but it can
start from the mouth also that's a whole
different
topic yeah yes everything's connected so
now that you're doing the raw eggs but
like you have the chickens and like it's
free-range chickens they're over here
living that good good
living that good life with those raw
eggs you do perfectly fine with compared
to the conventional eggs
i've i've let off for a little bit now
so i haven't
i haven't gone back but i'm gonna
inshallah
introduce it again probably soon okay
yeah
because i'm asking man because the the
real question that i had is like
from your perspective do you think that
if people were to start going to a more
uh whole food based diet and let's say
people were to start
you know farming their own foods and
having their own permaculture and
just being sustained off that like do
you think
that these uh intolerances allergy stuff
that we have do you think that that
would
pretty much be taken care of and be gone
with
i think there's a by itself this is
proof and of itself people's just
testimony in their lives being
transformed there's a great documentary
i think it's called fat
sick and almost dead have you any of you
guys seen that i heard of it yeah
yeah fat sick and almost dead he was on
like 12 prescription drugs
and nothing was working and then he just
started to do it at all juicing
he just started juicing juicing and then
it's compared compared it to a fish tank
so the fish tank is all just full of
toxic chemicals it's dirty
you just start adding more things to it
instead of
taking all the old water out you know
cleansing the
cleaning up that fish tank same thing
with the body so now
one by one he started to get off these
medications because he started to
put into his body you know things that
are going to help to nourish it and
clean it out
so and then he was alhamdulillah he was
healed and you have so many
stories like this so many people who who
have uh you know beat many of the common
disease reversed
many of the diseases through the food
through eliminating certain foods and
bringing in certain foods
and like that statement from hypocrites
that you quoted let food be your
medicine and medicine be your food
they started treating the food as a
medicine as a healing and that goes back
to what the prophet saw some said
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind he said for every disease
allah god almighty sent the cure he sent
the cure
not symptom management send the cure
right so the cure is out there
and you just have to go and take the
means
and whatnot but the people have to
differentiate drugs between real
medicine and it's out there
bro i got no more questions but if you
all do then
let it be known does that include cancer
you have uh you have so many people
again see this is like uh
this is uh really there's a crispy
cancer
chris b cancer he's got a lot of
testimonials
he's someone who beat cancer himself and
alhamdulillah
i mean it's allah god almighty who gives
the healing we take the means
and put our trust in the crater that
happens in the earth but i was amazed
i was amazed i interviewed this guy his
name is chris
beat cancer and he has
i don't know how many people testimonies
of people who changed
their food intake they started to
make adjustments and things uh
things changed you know they started to
reverse i just googled it chris beat
cancer has like over three thousand
reviews
five stars it's just natural healing for
uh
cancer so i've had him on the show i've
interviewed him and
he um he talks here's one interview for
people who like ice cream
uh ben and jerry's or anything is ben
and jerry's one he has an interview with
i think uh john is it hopkins or he
ju he was the son he was about to
inherit
his father's kingdom meaning the ice
cream kingdom but he got into health
and he knew that the ice cream that his
father is selling
that it's it's poisoning people so
he ended up trying to get his get out of
this
he got out of it he wrote a book on
health his father
and many of his family members ended up
dying from cancer
his father actually ends up at the doc
it's a very interesting story
ends up at the doctor who recommends a
book that happens to be his son's book
that talks about health and wellness and
so he was he was somebody
who uh shed the light on his ice cream
now again you can substitute it where
you can take frozen bananas
frozen fruits you can go through a
juicer and that can come out and you can
actually make
you can make hosts when we i don't want
people to get the wrong impression like
oh you're just
cutting out everything in life no you
just replace it with something better
so you take that snicker bar you place
it with a date you take that pop-tart
you
replace it with some bananas and
strawberries you
you replace that that uh ice cream from
the stores
that's poison your body with a natural
ice cream right that you can make from
frozen fruit fruits you can go ahead and
and make it through the
to the juice machine it comes out
swirled and you got natural ice cream
yeah so always you can replace these
things with something that's more
wholesome pure yeah it's a marathon not
a sprint and that's that's what
food that's what brother eddie was
saying that's what the deen as well with
islam is not
nothing's gonna happen overnight but you
don't know how long you have so you
might as well make every day
a step forward then a step backward yes
that's a good point you mentioned
because a lot of these things people
don't have patience
so look how long you've been poisoning
your body
so now how long it's going to take for
you you got to have some patience now
you got when you start introducing these
new methods these lifestyle hacks it's
going to take a little bit of time but
you're on your way
to a better future inshallah yeah
my brother eddie is there anything else
you wanna you wanna say before we wrap
it up
uh for the for the people out there just
push the final final word
uh final rule i always remind people
this life is short
you know uh we just been talking about
health take it serious because this is
the honoring
the the vehicle that god almighty allah
gave us to get us through life is so
so important right so honor your body
this gift that the creator has given us
through putting the good foods in there
you know nourishing not only the mind
body
but also the soul this is the key thing
you know connecting it to its creator
and remembering like we first started
this life is short you know allah says
in the quran
every soul will take death so we as
muslims we live a complete life
we went from talking about finding
purpose we talked about
over here about food about nutrition uh
so it's the cool thing we're talking
about cool things important things
right so get away from wasting time
get into things that are going to be
make you productive they're going to
help you live a holistic
fruitful life so you can get the
benefits of this life but also you
prepare yourself for the ultimate place
that you're striving for setting the gps
to jenna
because that's where is the final abode
in sha allah that we're
trying to strive for and avoiding the
hellfire
guys with that being said if you made it
this far comment down below
hashtag bring eddie back because we
definitely need him for part two
to talk more on sport mma a little more
on training because
i feel like we didn't talk about a lot
of stuff in this one episode
and we try to keep it short because
people got short attention spans
nowadays
but rami do you think bro with that
being said
it was an amazing episode and we hope to
have you back soon insha'allah to all
the viewers
like comment subscribe check out our
patreon and please check out the dean's
show all the videos mentioned in sha
allah the books recommended
and please take the advice that brother
eddie has shared today in sha allah
with that being
give my own experience with this because
when my mom had gotten
surgery she got part of her liver
removed
she was out of commission for a year
and the entire time like i didn't do
anything for her
i was just basically hanging out with my
girlfriend
going to parties doing drugs drinking
spending time with friends basically
ducking her and my sister
was taking care of her the entire time
now my sister
didn't say anything but like after the
fact
years later i reflected on that myself
and i was like damn like that was really
rough
you know that was really rough for me to
do that to my own mother
i'd probably be questioned about that on
the day of judgment and like
that's me being a self-reflective person
being able to see that but like if my
sister would have said
what i had told you to say like i'm sure
at that moment in time it would've hit
[Music]
[Music]
um